where the mouse the mouse devours all so
I'm gonna talk about something that I
have been avoiding talking about up to
this point now the news that Disney and
Fox had entered some degree of
negotiations for Disney to purchase
portions of Fox's business that news
broke a couple of weeks ago but I've
avoided talking about it pretty much for
the same reason that I really rarely
talk about when an actor or director is
only in talks to be involved in a movie
project that otherwise would be
something I talk about because I don't
like to waste the time the effort of the
brain power you know dedicated to going
over all this stuff that is only in
talks that maybe that'll happen I like
when things are set like this is what we
actually plan to do that's what I like
to talk about it now as of the recording
of this a deal has not been officially
formally finalized but the report is is
that a deal was struck
they just haven't announced it yet and
we have a pretty good image of what that
deal looks like so before I start
getting into this what it means for
various aspects of things or what I
think it could mean you know different
ways things could go I do want to point
out before anybody starts going out and
despite my little intro bit all the
people who are terrified that Disney
wants to control everything please keep
in mind that this was not a situation of
Disney approached Fox going we want to
consume you Fox very clearly wanted to
unload a number of things this was a
motivated seller situation because
Disney wasn't even the only ones they
were talking to they were talking to
comcast they were talking to Verizon
it's just Disney's the one that actually
went the distance on it so what Fox has
basically unloaded when what Disney has
purchased appears to be the 21st Century
Fox film and television production
studios and all of the creative assets
that's involved in that and there's a
few other things involved in the deal
the Annie Network Star TV Nat Geo and a
couple of smaller things like that it
does not look like the Fox Network is
part of the deal I actually think it
can't because I don't think that Disney
is allowed to own
more than one broadcast network because
they already own ABC so that kind of
leaves up in the air and what happens to
the Fox Network I figure one of two
things happens and either they try and
sell that off to somebody else or they
just let it die I think that might be
the more likely situation because since
Fox and since Disney is acquiring all of
the production elements and all of the
and the rights and control of all of the
stuff that Fox had the network itself
kind of becomes not worth very much you
basically literally just get the right
to broadcast on this channel but you get
none of the stuff that was already
existing on it and in case folks are
wondering the reason Fox is doing all
this and unloading all this stuff is
they have made a decision as a company
that they can't compete with the Giants
of scripted entertainment basically and
they see that right now as disney amazon
netflix they've decided that they can't
win that game so they're gonna get out
of that game and instead as a company
they're gonna focus pretty much
exclusively on news and sports and
things like that which they feel they've
got a much better foot in and a leg up
on so what does disney now actually take
control of quite a bit actually there's
the stuff that you know I'm going to
spend the majority of this video talking
about let's put that off for a second
talk about some of the other stuff just
real quick just to touch on it just to
give you an idea of everything that
Disney is now acquired because it is all
of the snit is gonna be all of the stuff
that Fox had the rights to so that means
the Simpsons family Guy Bob's Burgers
the Alien franchise the predator
franchise the Planet of the Apes
franchise and I mean a ton of other
stuff it's a lot of stuff and there's
gonna be a lot of options for what they
will or won't do with it now obviously
the main sort of goal for them and
acquiring this stuff was undoubtedly the
x-men and Fantastic Four franchises and
as
I'm gonna get to those a little bit
later they're gonna take up the bulk of
this video anyway but just to touch on
the other stuff because Fox does have a
number of fairly substantial
adult-oriented
material I'm not sure whether or not you
could say that Simpsons is necessarily
adults it's more upper teens but family
guys pretty adult alien predator I mean
those are traditionally r-rated
franchises and I'm sure there's some
people out there going Disney's got a
tournament too pg-13 people forget
Disney does release r-rated movies just
not under the Disney banner they do it
through touchstone or you know they have
they have means to release more adult
stuff like I mean the net foot the
Marvel Netflix stuff is if that material
have been released in film it all would
have been rated R so you know don't
automatically assume just because Disney
now controls something that it's going
to be made pg-13 or PG it's a question
of where it fits into things overall and
a lot of these properties are too
valuable for them to just sit on again I
have no doubt these a lot of the things
I just listed are secondary to the main
thing Disney's after so we might not
hear about new plans on them for a
little while but they're not just gonna
vanish into the ether that's not gonna
happen cuz then you're just you're
you're leaving money on the table that
way so that brings us to really the main
thing that you expect a channel called
Council of geeks to talk about which is
the Marvel properties that will now be
reclaimed under the Marvel banner so
Fantastic Four there isn't really too
much to talk about there was nothing
being done with a either a follow up to
fan for stick or another reboot so
Marvel can just do whatever they want
with it
x-men however is a bit of a different
beast because that is still that was
still an ongoing concern so the question
is what happens now what happens to the
to the films and the projects that were
already more or less done but haven't
been released yet what happens to the
ones that were being worked on what
happens after all of that as far as
x-men goes and I have a number of
thoughts about all this so I'm kind of
go
run through things a bit so for x-men
there are three films x-men related that
are scheduled to come out next year that
are basically already shot and are in
some degree of post-production meaning
that you know they you know they've
still got effects to do you know music
all that stuff but the first one that's
up is New Mutants and that's scheduled
for an April release I don't see that
changing I figure that still comes out
as planned because it's yeah I
anticipate it's probably gonna be pretty
standalone in and of itself so it can be
a complete story and then they can
decide whether or not something they
want to follow up on later Deadpool is
gonna be an odd one Deadpool 2 will
still get released there's no question
about that because it is a you know a
massively popular film and then the
movies more or less done and at the very
least is already shot at this point and
it would just look bad it would be a bad
waste of fan goodwill they'd lose a lot
of it if they didn't release that
because oh it's not family-friendly but
that thing I said before about the fact
that that Disney and even Marvel are not
adverse to dealing in more r-rated
material
I think Deadpool is in a little bit of
an awkward place because Deadpool is
very much on our rated property but the
problem is if Disney gets ahold of them
that means potentially he ends up tying
directly into their pg-13
family-friendly line of properties and
there's a possibility Disney might get
antsy about that and be a little bit
uncomfortable with it so I figure
there's a couple of possible outcomes
there's the possibility that Ryan
Reynolds and the other sort of creatives
behind the Deadpool franchise just
aren't able to see eye-to-eye to Disney
they walk away and then for my money
Disney puts Deadpool on ice cuz I'd like
to think they have enough understanding
to realize as popular as the character
is it is Ryan Reynolds as the character
that is really the push right now and so
recasting and going in a new direction
would be a very bad idea
assuming that that isn't the case
because we like it I don't think they
would do this but if Disney's
okay we'll keep Deadpool but he's gotta
be pg-13 now I think Ryan Reynolds and
the rest of them would walk they spent
so much energy trying to ensure it was
r-rated in the first place they're not
gonna stick her on if it's bumped down
to pg-13 so the question then becomes
what do they do with him and I don't
think they would just want to put him on
ice because like I said he's really
popular he's really valuable right now
as an intellectual property but like I
said there I I suspect Disney would get
very uncomfortable with him having
immediate direct ties to to the Marvel
Universe the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and before people tell me well the
Netflix shows have a tie-in to it yeah
but first of all it's through a
different delivery method so there's an
immediate sort of bit of a wall there
and they haven't had really direct
crossovers they all technically happen
in the same universe but it's been a
couple of vague mentions it doesn't even
have the level of crossover that agents
of shield has so I don't think that's
comparable so if if they allow Deadpool
to continue as a franchise for my money
they do not allow for crossover between
anything that appears in the Deadpool
franchise and however they plan to use
x-men and the rest of the MCU because
you know that's going to happen I'll
talk more about that later so what I
mean by that is say Deadpool 3 happens
after this deal closes and you know
dizzy and Marvel Disney now has control
of Deadpool Deadpool 3 happens Colossus
won't appear in it he'll be moved over
to x-men but characters like Cable
Domino copycat negasonic teenage warhead
they will remain in Deadpool only and
they won't cross over to the MCU they'll
probably let Deadpool have his little
meta references you know cuz he's a
fourth-wall breaking character but they
won't make explicit connections between
the their ongoing MCU franchise and
Deadpool they're gonna basically put him
in the side so that he's not directly
tying in for my money that's what they
end up doing the next movie next year
that is supposed to be released is x-men
Dark Phoenix now this one is the only
one of the three I think there's a
possibility I don't think it's likely
but there's a possibility that it may
not actually get released and I think
there's a couple of things that play to
determine what that is so I'm gonna try
and set us on my own certainty at the
fact that and that this thing's gonna
suck but even setting that aside as best
as I can I figure there's a couple of
issues that Marvel has regarding this
movie because obviously I doubt they'd
like already know now how they're gonna
integrate x-men into the MCU but those
plans are gonna be starting to put into
place and by the time x-men Dark Phoenix
comes out which isn't until November
they're gonna know what those plans are
and if the movie doesn't jibe with those
plans or it doesn't feel like it allows
them to really do what they want to do
that might be a reason to scrubbing and
what I mean by that is there's no chance
that the x-men universe as we have known
it for the past Wow 17 years is going to
be integrated into the MCU x-men
characters absolutely will be but
they're not gonna try and take that
world that we know with that cast in
those characters and move it over that's
not gonna happen
so they may decide by then and like as
that Deadpool probably exists in his own
pocket New Mutants probably could this
is this one's gonna be dealing with the
characters that Marvel itself is going
to want to use and they may just go you
know what we do want to be able to get
to our thing now I think the best shot
Dark Phoenix has is if it is either
already been made to be or could be
retrofitted to be a final chapter for
that x-men franchise and what I say
retrofitted to be I mean it doesn't come
out until November there's a knife and
there's enough time to do reshoots to
make adjustments but I don't mean like
drastically changed the ending so
everybody dies I mean just bring it on
to a conclusion make sure it doesn't
like end with a clear set of first
sequel have it end on a note that very
much feels like we have finished this
story this is all done and if they can
do that maybe it comes out another
possibility why they might not release
it though and this is bringing my bias
into the thing which is that if they
get a look at the cut as it currently
exists and decide that it just looks bad
they might kill it because of regardless
of how much money has already been spent
on the thing and you know traditional
logic says you have a finished product
why not just release it and make
whatever you can off of it it could be
damaging to the x-men brand and Disney
have done something like this before a
lot of people may not remember this but
right before Disney bought Lucasfilm and
Star Wars there was a completed animated
series called Star Wars detours done by
a number of people who had worked on
Robot Chicken and it was it was a series
of you know very spoofy comedic sketches
working with Star Wars characters and
all of that and whence once Disney got
ahold of the Star Wars property they
killed that dead and it was done the
entire thing was done but they made the
determination that that approach of
mocking Star Wars was damaging to the
brand for what they wanted to do in
terms of reviving it as an ongoing film
franchise again if they see x-men Dark
Phoenix and believe it's gonna be
damaging to the brand how in the form
that it currently exists and it's not
worth the cost to try and fix it they
might actually just scrub it again I
don't necessarily think that's likely
but it is a possibility I want to say
it's a possibility just in case it turns
out that I called it now there's a few
other x-men related things that are in
much earlier stage of development
supposedly the gambit movie was finally
getting somewhere for my money that
probably ends up never happening I
suppose it depends on whether they were
locked down on the script or they're
still in the scripting phase if they're
still in the scripting phase on gambit
it's possible that they could get in
there and make the adjustments to the
script to have it fit whatever plan they
come up with - to bring these characters
into the MCU so maybe it still happens
but it's way less likely now than it
ever was and it was kind of a 50/50 shot
at best in the first place so the
question then becomes what about after
the stuff that was already planned under
Fox
what does Marvel do with the x-men and
yes I have talked about this before how
I didn't want Marvel to get control of
bi
smen back but my thoughts in that video
which i standby don't matter at this
point because they are getting it back
so I need to just settle that aside if
you're wondering why I thought that was
a bad idea
check out that video I'll put a link
below for that but you know this is
happening so let's try and figure out a
way that they could do it so I think in
a way this is actually really good for
Disney and for Marvel in terms of the
MCU because it's gonna give them some
real premiere stuff to work with after
the end of infinity war and obviously
they've got some things already lined up
after infinity war you know Captain
Marvel happens after that the third
guardians movie happens after that but
the thing to remember is unlike the
comic book characters on the page actors
age and at this point you know maybe
they'll stick around for a while longer
but eventually our first wave of Heroes
meaning Robert Downey jr. Chris
Hemsworth Chris Evans Scarlett Johansson
all these folks are eventually going to
stop doing this either because they
decide they really want to focus on
other things or that they just have aged
out of it or what-have-you for any
number of reasons these actors will
eventually stop playing these parts and
so they have to have new characters to
push forward and have get in there now
they've already done some legwork in
terms of that we now we're gonna have
Black Panther as I mentioned Captain
Marvel if that does really well I dead
certain we're going to get a MS Marvel a
little bit later on if Captain Marvel
does well enough so I have no doubt they
have plans in place but that's very much
a case of them having to build up AI I
don't want to undermine these characters
a lot of these are great characters but
lesser-known kind of second-tier level
Marvel characters and try and premiere
them as a big deal and convince
audiences that they are a big deal but
you know what would do a lot of that
work for them if they could just
introduce Wolverine I mean like right
off the bat that saves them so much
trouble and there's all these characters
across the x-men that just being able to
bring them in becomes a celebration in
and of itself and immediately sort of
re-energizes things and it gives them a
clear path of where they can take things
that was different from what the MCU was
doing prior to infinity war so it
actually opens up a lot of possibilities
in many ways the question that becomes
how do you actually integrate them into
this because I think the worst thing
that you could do would be to imply that
mutants are a new thing and like they
just started happening because that
unfortunately that idea undermines
greatly a lot of the allegory and a lot
of the metaphor that is at the heart of
x-men it's important that they've been
around for a while it's important that
people are uncomfortable with them and
have been it's important that people
were born this way and that it is
genetic and you know there are there has
been a generation of mutants that has
already had children who are mutants you
know this has to have been around for a
while
so I think doing a thing where it's like
mutation is suddenly starting to happen
all over the world that doesn't work and
especially doesn't work with because
that really only allows you to have a
crap-ton of teenagers that doesn't allow
for Professor X of any reasonable age
doesn't allow for Magneto
to be his contemporary it doesn't allow
for Wolverine to be God knows how old so
forget that that doesn't work what might
work and and this is this is me
spitballing an idea that it basically
came up with today so you know give me a
little leeway here but what might work
is if you introduce that Professor X and
his school from well first of all you
make mutation probably a more rare
occurrence than it was in Fox's Marvel
Fox's x-men movies so you have Professor
Charles Xavier and his school for the
gifted is not just about finding young
mutants to you know raise them with a
certain philosophy and help them get a
handle on their powers it's also just
about hiding them and keeping them out
of the public eye and
I could even see like Charles Xavier
knowing Nick Fury and Nick Fury being
like look I know that this is going on
but if you can keep these people
contained keep in train them how to use
their power you don't make waves
I'll keep everybody off your back I
could see that kind of relationship
working now doing that would necessitate
a little bit of a shift in how Professor
X is traditionally depicted because
usually professor X's dream is all about
human and mutant harmony everybody lives
together and everybody is happy with
each other and they all dance around the
campfire and sing Kumbaya and I
understand that that is sort of the core
of the character from the comics the
thing is that we already got a really
super comic accurate version in the form
of Patrick Stewart in the previous
franchise and I think since we already
had that trying to stay as true to the
comics version as he already was you're
just gonna go oh I wish we sell Patrick
Stewart so I think it makes to make
sense to go a slightly different
direction and maybe Heaven be a little
more cynical maybe have him hope that
one day and wishful that there could be
you know some kind of integration
between humans of mutants but maybe he's
a little bit more of a pragmatist and
maybe he's more focused on just keeping
mutants safe and you could still have
that contrast between him and Magneto
where magneto says we shouldn't be
hiding we should be superior so you know
you can still have that conflict even if
Charles is trying to keep mutants as a
whole hidden and protected and I think
that would be more of a way to do it in
terms of seating the idea that they have
been here for a while but also
explaining why we haven't seen them over
the course of about a decade worth of
these movies already but as I said
anybody who's being like Hugh Jackman's
gonna be in that movie with Captain
America no he's not he's done with this
part Logan was very much him ending his
tenure in this role they're going to
introduce the x-men they're definitely
gonna introduce Wolverine but it's gonna
be another actor and it's probably gonna
be a decidedly different take because
honestly it should be because otherwise
you end up with a Hugh Jackman imitator
he wants that although actually you know
I mentioned Wolverine several times for
my money they hold off introducing him
until they get some other x-men in there
I bet you they put the focus more on
some of the characters that we're always
kind of there but really never felt like
they had their proper spotlight like
perhaps Cyclops
maybe storm maybe use Kitty Pryde you
know folks that have been seen in the
other movies but we're never the main
ones front and center because you know
those are the ones that that audiences
are gonna be the most sort of wistful
for the version that we had for a long
time so I think the character you do
have to have Charles Xavier you kind of
have to there's no way around that so
they better cast real smart with that
but I think Wolverine you gotta put to
the background if they allow Dark
Phoenix to come out as a movie they'll
probably want to put Jean Grey in the
background beast maybe put in the
background and Magneto maybe hold off on
him for a little bit
keep the mystique as well unfortunately
she's now been overexposed so I think
their best bet will be to not not like
never do but for the introduction of the
x-men to try and start out with familiar
faces but not the ones that have been
the primary face of the x-men franchise
when it was under Fox so that they can
get their footing onto them and then
introduce the Disney version of the
better known characters like Wolverine
magneto Jean Grey mystique etc so those
are my general thoughts I as much as I
railed against the idea of Disney
reclaiming x-men as a franchise before
at this point I've kind of I've accepted
that it's going to happen in my ideal
world it wouldn't be happening but it is
gonna happen and there are a lot of good
potential things to come out of it I am
you know what
I haven't mentioned yet there's the TV
end of things so there's a couple of
x-men shows on right now there's gifted
which has not been confirmed to get a
second season yet anyway so for my money
that probably just doesn't get renewed
and they have it just be the one season
maybe it's the second season but from my
understanding because I still haven't
seen gifted from my understanding it has
more explicit clear connections to the
Mara the x-men universe as Fox was doing
it then something like Legion which I'll
talk about in a second so because of
that then that would that would be one
more reason for Disney just to leave it
at one season and not give it anything
more after that which from what I hear
I've heard generally positive things
that might end up being a shame Legion
is I may have already shot her it's in
the process of shooting its second
season right now they'll probably let
that happen because Legion is very much
it has like one Easter Egg II connection
to the x-men franchise as a whole but is
largely its own bizarre little thing so
they'll probably let season two happen
after that I don't know because on an
odd thing that I couldn't find X did not
appear to be part of what Disney was
buying like I mentioned some of the
other channels they were getting any Nat
Geo whatever but FX wasn't among them
and that strikes me as odd and that is
also slightly concerning to me because I
want to know what's gonna happen to that
network and the shows that are on it
because FX has some of the best TV going
right now it's got Legion it's got Fargo
it's got American Horror Story American
crime story it's you know well not a FX
X and now but it's it's the home of
Archer it there's wonderful but
decidedly adult aimed material on FX and
so far as I can tell it was not part of
the deal that that Disney was taking
over that Network so I don't know what
happens after that I suppose the
question is how many of those
shows were in-house productions or were
being produced by basically other
entities and were simply airing on FX I
I wasn't prepared to do that level of
research to find out but I really hope
that the shows that I just listed don't
end up cancelled or homeless or
what-have-you
so I think that's about it I have no
idea how long this is gonna be I have
rambled on a long time I'm not looking
forward to editing this but Disney
buying a whole bunch of Fox stuff what
are your thoughts on it whatever they
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter our
Council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast that's
available on Apple podcast and stitcher
radio
I'm also 1/2 of the punch like a girl
podcast that is a presentation of the
fire and water podcast network Fire and
Water podcast comm links for all this
stuff is down below and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]